cette semaine est-ce que les métis rni
une de leurs cultures ou et bienvenue à
paroles autochtone si c'est melissa
maulin depuis cette semaine je vais
répondre à la question de piques qui me
demandent justement est-ce que les métis
revenus une de leur culture et comme dit
il faut vraiment établir qu'est ce qu'on
veut dire par métis donc comme c'était
pas défini je prendre la peine de
l'expliquer la nation métisse
c'est une culture c'est une nation donc
ironie personnes ce sont leurs identités
qu'ils ont défini eux mêmes et qui est
reconnue autant par les premières
nations par les communautés autochtones
que par le gouvernement canadien est
donc j'ose imaginer que cela ne concerne
pas la nation métisse de l'ouest qui est
établi et qui a les mêmes droits télés
programmations ou que les peuples inuit
dans ce que je comprend l'application
pixee tu parles plus de l'identité
métissée
alors là c'est un peu plus compliqué à
définir parce qu'être métissée ça veut
dire que tu as un parent qui est
autochtone et en parents qui ne l'est
pas et même le sar ans est encore plus
compliqué parce que ici tant par an
qu'il n'y ait pas docteur mais qui a des
origines autochtones et que l'autre
parent est autochtone mais je n'ai
jamais vécu dans la communauté
quelle culture et remixé que c'est quoi
donc je vais partir juste du point de
vue personnel de moi ce que j'ai vu
quand j'étais jeune ou est ce que moi je
suis unis nous avec un père québécois
qui est élevé dans ma communauté un
manga mais aussi en ville donc on peut
parler d' identité métissée mais quand
on me demande de quelle nation je suis
je réponds clairement je suis unis nous
j'ai été élevée par une mère et nous
s'était clairement la nation qui était
le plus impliqué dans ma jeunesse dans
dans mon identité dans ce que ce qui m'a
été donné de grandir mais la nation
québécoise de la gale mot revient
extrêmement présente aussi mais pour moi
c'était clairement que j'étais unis nous
avec un père québécois
la différence c'est que l'été j'allais à
montréal pour les vacances
je vivais plus du côté où ce que je
regardais si je regardais de l'intérieur
vers l'extérieur
la sculpture qui était plus extérieur à
moi tu es la culture québécoise mais ce
qui a fait que c'était vraiment les deux
m'appartenait c'est que j'ai jamais
cherché à renier une des deux cultures
pour moi c'est d'ailleurs une des
raisons pourquoi j'ai fait avec moi
pourquoi je me suis impliqué dans la
réconciliation c'est que j'ai à coeur
les deux nations et quand le monde me
demandait de choisir
eh bien là c'est lorsque je devais
expliquer la raison pourquoi on me force
à choisir c'est que l'identité des
premières nations
l'identité des inuit toutes les
identités autochtones au canada sont
régis par et la loi sur les indiens et
le droit canadien
c'est une des seules identité ou une loi
décide à un moment donné quand tu n'es
plus un indien inscrits ou un autochtone
donc y'a personne d'autre autour de moi
qui étais obligée de choisir entre une
nation ou l'autre québécois d'origine
irlandaise ou un haïtien qui est né ici
avec une maman québécoise et il y avait
juste dans cet automne à laquelle on
demande toujours de faire un choix parce
que cette loi fait basculer ton identité
d'un côté ou de l'autre
donc ces ports une décision qui vient de
notre nation c'est vraiment un choix qui
est imposé par la colonisation
j'espère que tu comprends que ça peut
pas être un rooney d'une nation ça ne
peut être qu'un choix qui est imposé
donc moi je n'ai pas eu à faire de choix
on m'a jamais demandé dans reniant ou
l'autre d'un côté ou l'autre de ma
famille donc pour moi je suis et je
reste unie nous avec des origines
québécoises aussi du côté de mon père
mais je me définis pas comme une métisse
je me définis comme unis nous et ça peut
être compliqué pour chaque personne que
tu vas rencontrer donc il faut vraiment
comprendre l'impact de la loi sur les
indiens sur cette question là parce
qu'elle existerai pour aucune autre
nation à part celle des premières
nations
alors merci pic pour ta question tu peux
imaginer que c'est compliqué alors
n'hésitez pas à partager les vidéos
n'hésitez pas à demander des
clarifications à envoyer des questions
justement parce que c'est une question
qui est d'avenir et qui va vraiment
faire bouger les choses au canada je
souhaite une bonne semaine